who do you like to dance absolutely
Elizabeth Thornton was happily dancing
with Lucas Bouchard that is until she
locked eyes with Mountie Nathan grants
that cliffhanger is how season six of
when calls the heart ended but what does
it all mean you'll have to turn MMC ET
spoke exclusively with showrunner
Alfonso H Marino
he told us Elizabeth asked Lucas to
dance over Nathan simply because Lucas
pursued her more
he also said there's a reason why
Elizabeth and Lucas's interaction didn't
involve a kiss quote ultimately we all
believed that we couldn't take it that
far we wanted to be respectful of the
fact that Elizabeth had recently been
widowed and had a baby as an executive
producer I am curious about this
conscious decision to not see Elizabeth
rush into a romance is this something
that you guys sat down really thoroughly
talked about you know I think we were
all on the same page about it no one
after spending five seasons building up
this romance between Jack and Elizabeth
and really falling for their connection
I think it would be pretty jarring for
our audience to suddenly see Elizabeth
with a new guy so we really are taking
our time with it she's really starting
to find her happiness again Lucas is
trying to plant a little seed and isn't
sure if it's gonna be developed or not
there might be some chemistry
Elizabeth's love triangle wasn't the
only major moment in the finale Jesse
and Clara took their relationship to the
next level will you be my wife
I haven't been working two jobs not
severe away
[Music]